Transcriber: reema alrabah
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
كلنا في حياتنا اليومية تواجهنا أفكار.
هذه الأفكار تكون نابعة من تحدياتنا في
العمل، أو في علاقاتنا الشخصية الإنسانية .
عندما تخطر الفكرة -والحصول على الأفكار ليس
بالأمر السهل- لكن نعتقد أن هذه الفكرة
مميزة.
فكرة قد يكون فيها شيء من الابداع،
شيء من الجمال
نبدأ ، نضع تصورا ما كي نخرج به
بنتائج لهذه الفكرة.
لكن مرحلة التخطيط هذه، قد تكون مرحلة
يبدأ فيها العقل البشري بالنظر للعوائق أو
الموانع، أكثر مما أن يركز على
النتائج الإيجابية للفكرة.
ممكن أقول أنا لا، هذه الفكرة
صحيح انها فكرة مميزة
لكن تطبيقها صعب عليّ، ليس لديّ
الآن، الإمكانات التي تساعدني
على التنفيذ أو التطبيق،
أو تحويلها إلى واقع، أو حقيقة
أو امكانية.
أقول ليس لدي الوقت أو الجهد، أو لا أؤمن
بأن لدي الطاقة، كما قالت أحدى السيدات.
حين هُيئ لها، أو صُور لها أنها لا تستطيع.
الرؤية ضبابية والنتائج لا يمكن التنبؤ بها.
قد تكون أيضا من العوائق التي
تقف في وجه تطبيق الفكرة.
فماذا يحدث؟ ما يحدث هو إننا للأسف
حينما نواجه بعض الأمور،
نلقي الفكرة وراء
ظهورنا، و نقول أنا لا أقدر
على تطبيقها حاليا
ممكن في وقت آخر، أتخلى عن الفكرة أو أبعدها
لفترة معينة من الزمن .
المؤسف في الموضوع، أنه قد أرى غيري
خطرت له فكرتي وطبقها ونجح فيها،
وأكاد أجزم أن
كلنا مررنا بهذا الموقف، فنشعر
بالغصه والالم.
بالطبع نتمنى لهم الخير والتوفيق،
لكن يقول الشخص هذه فكرتي يا ليتني بدأت،
ياليتني نفذتها.
عودنا و علمنا دائما لأن ننجح
أو تنجح الفكرة، يتوجب لها عوامل معينة.
فكرة مميزة تحمل شيء من الإبداعية.
التخطيط كذلك مهم، هو اغلب
المراحل التي تقف عائق
في تنفيذ الأفكار المميزة والتوقع
المستقبلي للفكرة،
خط السير و النتائج المحتملة
لكن دائما ننسى أننا نركز، على
عامل آخر .
ما هو هذا العامل؟ عامل اللا متوقع.
البشر عبارة عن كائن متطور، تستجد
في أمره أشياء كثيرة.
هذه الامور تمكننا من إنجاح
أي مساعي أو اي مشروع
خاصة إذا كانت الرؤية في البداية
والنتائج غير متوقعة أو غير ومتنبأ بها.
فهنا تأتي قوة اللا متوقع، التي تحدثتم
اليوم عنها قبل حديثي عنها.
لتقريب الصورة، هذه البذرة
تحتاج المكان الملائم
وتحتاج الأجواء الملائمة لكي تبدأ
بالنمو ثم تثمر .
قد لا نرى النتيجة النهائية حينما
وضعا البذرة في الأرض.
قد لا نرى أنه في النهاية الشجرة.
هذه سوف تثمر ثمر.
والمفارقة الجميلة التي تعلمتها، وأنا يعني
المعلومة الطريفة التي أحب مشاركتكم بها من
وقت بذرة التفاح، حتى أول محصول
للطرح خمس إلى ست سنوات .
لكن المزارع يصبر ويستمر ويكابر .
لماذا؟ قد لا يرى إن الشجرة
ستعطيه التفاح الآن
لكنه يرى البوادر أو أن النبتات الصغيرة
التي شقت طريقها
من باطن الأرض طلعت على السطح يوم
عن يوم بتكبر وهذا الذي أتكلم فيه .
أنا لا أتوقع نتائج من أول ما بذرت
البذرة، لكني أرى البوادر فاستمر.
يأتي نجاح المساعي من الأفكار المناسبة في
الوقت الملائم، وليس من توقع نتائجها.
هذا ما خرجت به من تجربة
عشتها أنا ورعيتها.
“ناجية“، نبعت من تعاملي مع السيدات
كوني استشارية في طب الأورام العلاجي، خصوصا
أورام الثدي.
هي فكرة نتجت من رؤيتي لحاجة السيدات للدعم،
للتواصل، لتبادل الخبرات في حيز آمن، في حيز
يضمن لهم المعلومة الصحيحة
دون أن يكون هناك إشاعات
خاطئة، للأسف منتشرة عن هذا
النوع من الأمراض.
بدأت فكرة بسيطة. الفكرة كانت مجموعات
أو حلقات دعم. لكن العوائق كانت كثيرة.
أولها أن كثير من السيدات لا
تظهر هويتهم الشخصية.
الامر الآخر أن كُثر ليس لديهم القدرة
على التنقل مثلا وحضور جلسة الدعم الواقعية
كما يحصل في الغرب.
بدأنا نفكر ماذا سيحدث لو حولناها
لمجموعات دعم افتراضية؟
وهي شراكة للمريضات المصابات،
والمتعافين، والطبيبات كذلك.
وهذا إنشاء المجموع.
المجموعة بدأت عام 2016،
وما تزال مستمرة حتى الآن.
بدأت بعدد لا يتجاوز أصابع اليد،
من السيدات المتعافيات ومعهن بعض الطبيبات .
توسعت حتى وصلت لمئات السيدات.
والطريف في الموضوع والذي لم أكن أتوقعه
ولا أحد توقع انها عبرت الحدود.
وهناك سيدات من الإمارات.
سيدات من اليمن.
سيدات من مصر.
العالم الافتراضي.
جمعنا كلنا.
وكذلك لم يكن متوقع أبدا
إن أحد المرشدين لي في مسيرتي العملية.
اقترح علي، بعد أن كبرت الفكرة وتوسعت،
أن أكتب عنها مقال علمي .
كتبت المقال، وإثر نشر المقال.
دُعيت لمؤتمرات، فازت ناجية
كبحث أصلي جديد
خاصة مثلما ترون الآن
بينما انتقل للعالم الافتراضي لها ست
سنوات وهي في العالم الافتراضي، قبل ظروف
الجائحه وما رافقها من توجهنا للعالم
الافتراضي.
وليس هذا فقط،
ولكن توجت ناجية بجائزة جدة
للإبداع المجتمعي 2021،
لخدمة المجتمع.
لو سألتموني أو سألت أحدى
السيدات اللواتي بدأن المشروع معي،
هل يتوقعون هذا النجاح؟ لا، ولا أحد.
هنا تكمن قوة اللا متوقع.
أتمنى لكم عاما جديدا سعيدا، بمسار واضح
وإن شاء الله ناتج واضح كذلك،
وشكرا على أنكم
الهمتوني اليوم.
عندما سمعت قصصكم.
شكرا جزيلا، سعيدة بتواجدكم.